Okay so here I am inside DevTools for our page.
And I've got the div selected that has our name and title.
It looks like we're in the right place but let's go ahead and
check Bootstrap's documentation, to figure out which classes we need.
I found this section about alignment classes in the CSS documentation.
It looks like we just need to add text-right to get Right aligned text.
Let's go ahead and try that out.
I'm back in DevTools.
And I will, double-click on the class to open it up.
I'll type in text-right, and press Enter.
And we see that our name and
title immediately pop to the right side of the screen.
So it looks like we're on the right track.
Let's see if we can get it capitalized.
Right underneath alignment,
we see transformation classes, including Uppercased text.
All we need to do is add the class text-uppercase.
Let's see if it works.
So now we have text-right and text-uppercase and I'll press Enter, and voila!
We have capitalized text that is aligned on the right.
So for right-align text, we just need text-right.
And to make text uppercase we simply add text-uppercase.
It worked for us when we added these classes to class equals col-md-6, but
in fact you could also add it to the h1 and h3 tags.
While adding it to h1 and h3 would work,
it's actually a lot cleaner when you add it to the div containing them.